I understand everything, democracy,
it is always necessary to remember the words, a
good word is backed up by a
machine gun. It is very good, let them
not be afraid if they think that
the war is somewhere there, the war in Europe is already going on
and it must be stopped immediately, in order to
stop it, it must be
completely crushed
and there will be no negotiations, but no  he
needs, as always, in such cases with
such
leaders to hit the bull, you know,
good and that's all Well,
I'm sorry, even Biden
is afraid of a major escalation, in short, I
don't know what to fear here
and they don't want to get involved
Ukraine will be in NATO only when the war
calms down a little and the war ends a little
with such an approach, we need an end to the
war, and then I hope that Ukraine will be
with us,
and here there will be some guarantees, as always,
some agreements, weapons, we will
see the budget of Chaos, they are afraid that
Russia will not reach such a level of
escalation that everything will be torn apart in
Russia This and that 100  % west of the fighters, so I
don’t know how And then how to win
if not specifically hit the gopnik with a
club on the head, I don’t know, we’ll
see what will happen on the site,
we won’t be able to reach any and
give up our territories that belong to us
since 1992.
That’s it  it will be a compromise because
a lot of people have died and it is
simply not something to
give up and live peacefully anymore and all this is already a
matter of principle and our people are waiting for Crimea
that Crimea will become ours again and we will
not give one piece of someone else's to us
we must, but we will not give up
ours, we must be accepted by NATO, because
peace in the whole world depends on it. Because
Russia is the aggressor, she will not stop. It is
not known what to expect from those crazy people.
And so it will be very, very
clear. The incentive to hold back is to be afraid.
Then they will be afraid.  the war may be afraid of an
attack and the war may end on
our terms, and on our terms, the
Russian Federation's absolutely clear and consistent position
is that the
membership of Ukraine
will have very, very negative
consequences for the entire
security architecture and the so-destroyed
security architecture in Europe.  And there
will be absolutely no
danger of a threat to our country that
we will need
sufficiently understandable TV